[موسيقى]
تحياتنا طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الا يشكل
فوز الرئيس التركي اردوغان صفعت كبرى لكل
الذين كانوا يراهنون على سقوطه الم تسقط
كل الرهانات على نهايه نهضه التركيه
الا يسارعون الان لراس الصدع مع انقره بعد
ان اصبحت بيضه القبان بين شرق والغرب
اليس متوقعا لها مستقبل مشرق بعد ان عاد
حزب العداله والتنميه الى الساحه التركيه
والدوليه اقوى من قبل
لكن في المقابل الم يترافق فوز اردووان
معا انهيار على كل الاصعده في الداخل
التركي وتوتر كبير مع الغرب الا يشكل
انهيار العمله التركيه والتضخم وتراجع
الاقتصاد التركي تحديا كبيرا للرئيس
التركي وحكومته ماذا يمكن للقياده التركيه
ان تفعل اكثر مما فعلت الا تبدو اليوم
وكانها تكفر عن اخطائها القديمه بتصحيح
علاقاتها مع الدول التي عادتها في الماضي
الم يصل الامر بالحكومه التركيه الى
مغازلتي حتى ما يسمى بالرئيس السوري الا
تواجه تركيا اليوم مخاطر داخليه جمه لم
يعد احد قادرا على معالجتها
اسئله اطرحها على حمزه كين رئيس تحرير
وكاله انباء تركيا وعلى الكاتب والاعلامي
الدكتور محمد بكر
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس لو بدات
معك حمزه في البدايه الف مبروك
تركيا الى اين بعد هذه الانتخابات التي
شغلت العالم اجمع
بدايه مبارك علينا جميعا هذا الانتصار
العظيم الذي تحقق في تركيا الذي احتفل به
كل العالم العربي والاسلامي والذي بارك
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان به عشرات
القاده حول العالم وبالتالي من هنا من
مشهد الاحتفال العالمي العربي الاسلامي من
حجم التبريكات والتهنئات التي وصلت لارايس
تركي رجب طيب اردوغان من زعماء العالم
نستطيع ان نجيب وان ندرك اين هي تركيا لو
لم تكن تركيا في المقدمه وعلى القمه قويه
لا ما احتفل العالم العربي الاسلامي ولم
اهتم يا دكتور هل تعلم ان قبل اربعه ايام
من الانتخابات التركيه كان هناك انتخابات
في اليونان هل سمع احد بهذه الانتخابات
انا اتحدى المشاهدين الكرام لم لم احد
كتبت هذه التغريده على تويتر ولم يسمع بها
احد وبالتالي اليونان هذا يعني دوله فاشله
دوله ضعيفه دوله لا قيمه لها بالبعد
الاقليمي والسياسي على عكس تركيا اليوم ان
يهتم بها كل العالم ان تاتي كل هذه
التبريكات وما زالت مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
للرئيس اردوغان اي ان تركيا في القمه لذلك
اليوم هذه القمه التي وصلنا اليها سياسيا
واقتصاديا وامنيا وعسكريا واستخباراتيا
بالسلاح التركي ضد الاعداء الان التحدي
الان التحديات كبيره وخطيره على الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تحديات داخليه
تحديات خارجيه ان نحافظ على قوه تركيا ان
نحافظ على القمه التي وصلنا اليها
وبالتالي نحن نعرف حجم التحديات وبالتالي
التحديات الكبيره لا تاتي الا للعظماء
التحديات الكبيره لا تاتي الا للدول
الكبرى المؤثره التحديات الكبيره لا يخرج
منها الذين يتعرضون لها الا اقوياء وها هي
تركيا اليوم يا سيدي الكريم كما ذكرت كل
العالم العربي والاسلام احتفل بفوز
اردوغان اعطني خلال العقد الماضي حدث في
العربي او الاسلامي احتفل به العرب
والمسلمون بهذا
الشكل حدث واحد فقط غير انتخاب اردوغان
الاحد الماضي حدث واحد احتفل به العرب
والمسلمون خلال العقد الماضي هو اسقاط
العمليه الانقلابيه الفاشله التي استهدفت
الرئيس اردوغان في 2016 اي ان العالمين
العربي والاسلامي احتفلوا مرتين بهذا
الحجم يوم حافظ التركي على اردوغان وتم
اسقاط الانقلابيين
وقبل يومين الاحد عندما فاز اردوغان
القضيه لم تكن انتخابات انتخابات القضيه
كانت اسقاط اردوغان هناك محاوله لاسقاط
اردوغان من قبل الاعداء الذين لا يريدون
ان تبقى تركيا
اليوم انتصرنا على الاعلام الغربي انتصرنا
على التصريحات الغربيه المقيته العنصريه
تجاه تركيا اليوم العالم العربي والعالم
الاسلامي انتصر مع تركيا هذا النصر يا
دكتور فيصل ومن هنا وللم هذا النصر لا
يعني اردوغان ولا يعني الشعب التركي ولا
يعني تركيا فحسب هذا النصر لكل العرب
والمسلمين لماذا لان اليوم تركيا تقدم
نموذجا بالقياده الحكيمه والنجاح رغم كل
التحديات هناك تحديات اقتصاديه هناك
تحديات سياسيه هناك اعداء هناك تحديات
عسكريه هناك عقوبات على تركيا هناك
مواجهات ولكن القوه الذي يفرحنا اننا امام
قياده قويه ما افرح هؤلاء الملايين انهم
راوا في اردوغان القائد القوي ونقطه على
السطر حلو القائد القوي اريد ان ابشر من
هنا من هنا ان رئيس تركيا اردوغان خلال
السنوات الخمسه المقبله سيحافظ على القمه
التي وصل اليها تركيا ستبقى في القمه
عسكريا وامنيا واستخباراتيا واقتصاديا
وساشرح خلال هذه الحلقه
وسنكون اقوى في المرحله المقبله تركيا
ستكون دوله في هذا العالم في النظام
العالمي الجديد سادس او سابع دوله انا لا
امزح ولا اتكلم كلام شعارات كما اسست كما
اسست نظام العالمي القديم الحالي يعني
وهناك خمسه دول اقوياء مجلس الامن هناك
نظام عالمي جديد يؤسس حاليا تركيا ستكون
من اول هذه الدول في النظام العالمي
الجديد شاء من شاء وابى من ابى دكتور هي
طيبه لك دكتور فيصل لضيفك ولمشاهديك
الكرام على العكس على الاطلاق اعتقد ان
تركيا مقبله على تحول كبير في المشهد خلال
الفتره القادمه تركيا امام مفترق خطير
وكبير لجهد تداعيات وما افرزته نتائج
الجولات الانتخابيه الاولى والثانيه افرزت
نحن اليوم امام انقسام كبير وعميق في
المجتمع التركي ليس ككل الانقسامات هذا
الانقسام خطير قاعدته الاساسيه
الانقسام هو بين تيار معارض تيار علماني
يمثل بك الجدار اوغلو حصل على الاصوات نصف
الشعب وبين تيار ديني اقرب للاصوليه وهذا
الانقسام بشئنا او ابينا بطبيعته
الايديولوجيه سوف يؤسس لانقسامات خطيره
ولتداعيات كبيره خلال الفتره القادمه على
المستوى السياسي على المستوى الاقتصادي
وربما على المستوى الميداني اعتقد يعني
ربما هنا افاجئ البعض واقول يعني ليحمدوا
الشعب التركي الله بانه فاز اردوغان لانه
لو خسر اردوغان هذه الانتخابات لكانت ذهبت
تركيا الى اقتتال كبير والى الهاويه لسبب
بسيط ماذا قال الرجل بوضوح في اليوم الذي
سبق الصمت الانتخابي قال عنوان الانتخابات
هو الصراع على بقاء تركيا وهذا يذكرنا
بالانظمه العربيه يعني اكون او لا اكون
انا او لا احد وبالتالي الى هذا الحد نعم
اذا هذا الحد واكثر اليوم هذا الانقسام
الذي اساسه الايديولوجيا لن يؤسس الى
استقرار للبلاد في تركيا سوف يكون له
تداعيات خطيره نعم فاز الرئيس اردوغان في
الانتخابات لكن السؤال الكبير هل انتهى
المشهد هنا بالتاكيد لا كما قلت لك تحدث
ضيفك عن الاحتفالات والشعب العربي وتعم
الارجاء العربيه انت كنت تقول يا دكتور
وانت عراب نظريه انكم لا تتسرعوا في اطلاق
الاحكام الشعب العربي والشعب الاسلامي
صحيح احتفل لكن منطلق هذا الاحتفال
العاطفه الشعب العربي عاطفي يتاثر بخطاب
هنا وبحديث هناك يرى مشهد للرئيس التركي
مثلا وهو يقرا القران يتاثر بهذا الشيء
لكن على الارض كل الوقائع مختلفه كل
المؤشرات سوف تختلف على المستوى السياسي
على المستوى الاقتصادي هناك مؤشرات صاغتها
مؤسسات وازنه ومؤسسات تركيه رسميه تؤكد
على ان المرحله المقبله مرحله خطيره جدا
لن تكون تركيا باحسان هذا الكلام قال انه
في تحديات كثيره لكن قادرون
يستطيع ان تكون هناك قدره على صياغه
الحلول لسبب بسيط لان التحديات اكبر بكثير
وساورد لك هذا بالتفصيل التحديات اكبر
اكثر بكثير من الامكانات الوعود التي
قدمها الرئيس التركي وعود ضخمه سوف يكون
الايفاء بها اقل ومن هنا عندما يكون
الايفاء بهذه الوعود خلال الفتره القادمه
قليل هذا سوف يؤسس لاحتقان كبير في المشهد
التركي ولن تكون تركيا بلد الاستقرار على
الاطلاق طيب لكن انقسام يعني لماذا لماذا
فقط عندما تحدث
انتخابات ديمقراطيه في بلد مثل تركيا نبدا
نسمع من العرب خاصه يعني انت تعلم العرب
لا عندهم ديمقراطيه ولا شيء يعني اخر
ديمقراطيه اخر انتخابات عملوها اجمل تيس
وفاز فيها كمان تعرف مين ما بعرف شو اسمه
القصه الان
يعني لماذا فقط في الحاله التركيه نحن
نعلم الانتخابات
الامريكيه الانتخابات البريطانيه
الانتخابات الفرنسيه الانتخابات
الاستراليه كلها تنتهي بهذه النتائج التي
حدثت في تركيا وربما اقل 50. لماذا لا
نتحدث عن انقسامات وخطوره وكذا الا في
الحاله التركيه كل المجتمعات الديمقراطيه
مجتمعات منقسمه على نفسها العبره في
النهايه بالتعايش هل المجتمع التركي
متعايش نعم متعايش بدليل ان هو كان هناك
احتقان كبير في الساحه التركيه اثناء فتره
الانتخابات احتقان كبير ماذا حدث بعد ان
فاز اردوغان عاد شعب الى اماكنه ونسوا كل
شيء وعاده الحياه الى طبيعتها وعادوا الى
التعايش هذا هو هذا يعني هذه قفزه عظيمه
بالمقاييس العربيه والاسلاميه فلماذا تصور
رياح انقسامات وانهيارات والى ما هناك
تفضل اعتقد ان صحيح نحن اليوم لسنا في صدد
نقاش على الانتخابات تركيا هي ديمقراطيه
او لا اكيد ديمقراطيه لكن لماذا العين على
تركيا وهذا التهويل على تركيا لان سياسه
الرئيس التركي كانت مختلفه عن كل الدول
الديمقراطيه التي ذكرتها لم تكن هناك دوله
تدخلت في عده جبهات بالكم الذي تدخل فيه
الرئيس التركي كان يقول منذ البدايه
امريكا تركت حدا ما دخلت معه في العالم
وهي اكبر ديمقراطيه لا نستطيع ان نقارن
امريكا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بتركيا
تركيا مهما اشتد بريق نجمها تبقى ضمن
اطارها الاقليمي
رحم الله امراه عرف قدره فوقف عنده اليوم
الرئيس التركي صح الانتخابات الديمقراطيه
هذا صحيح لكن كان يقول صدع رؤوسنا خلال
السنوات الماضيه انه يريد ان يصفر المشاكل
مع دول الجوار ومع المحيط يا رجل عداد
المشاكل وصل لمرحله الى ان ينفجر من كثر
من كثر المشاكل بالتاكيد التدخل في
الجبهات في العراق في مصر في سوريا في
اوروبا في شمال افريقيا
يعني هذه جمله التدخلات هي التي سلطت
العين على الرئيس التركي وهي التي تسلط
العين على الانتخابات التركيه وهي التي
تريد من كليجدار ان ينجح كونه اقرب الى
الفكر العلماني ويريد ان يسعى الى غربا
تركيا هذا هو السبب الرئيسي حمزه
الرجل يتحدث عن وجود انقسام خطير يعني
انتهت الانتخابات لكن الانقسام داخل
المجتمع التركي لم ينتهي بانتهاء
الانتخابات وفوز اردوغان وطبيعه الانقسام
على عكس يعني بنقل السؤال بطريقه معاكسه
على عكس الانقسامات
الديمقراطيه الموجوده في المجتمعات
الغربيه والدول الغربيه الانقسام داخل
تركيا
ذو منحى
ديني صحيح روحي فلهذا هو اخطر من غيره
الان في تركيا
47% من الاتراك يتجهون باتجاه علماني
المتطرف اذا صح التعبير متطرف في الان
ذاته الذين صوتوا لاردوغان يتجهون اتجاها
دينيا واضحا وقد شاهدنا رمزيات ذلك
بالصلاه في ايه صوفيا وغيرها من من تلك
المظاهر كيف ترد لا ابدا دعني بدايه ارد
على ضيفك الكريم عده نقاط النقطه الاولى
المقدمه التي تفضل بها ان تركيا الى
الانهيارات وان تركيا الى الفشل بعد هذه
الانتخابات نفس الكلام ذكره في مقاله له
في تموز عام 2016 بعد ان افشلنا وكسرنا
اقدام وايدي الانقلابيين نعم نعم قال ضيفك
الكريم في تلك المقاله قبل سبع سنوات نفس
الحرف نفس الكلام تركيا ذاهبه الى
الانهيارات والى فوضى كبرى هل يحسن
السلطان التدبير قبل تسع سنوات هذه
المقاله للضيف الكريم في جريده راي اليوم
وبالتالي هل حصل هل انهارت تركيا هل
تراجعت تركيا كلا وبالتالي كلام ضيفك
الكريم مع كل الاحترام لم يتحقق اي ان
كلامه الان في هذه المقدمه لن يتحقق اي ان
تركيا الى مزيد من القوه الى مزيد من
تطوير الصناعات الدفاعيه الى مزيد من
القوه الاقليميه والتاثير السياسي الرهيب
والقوي والعظيم في الاقليم وفي من الملفات
وخاصه كلنا نعلم التاثير التركي في القضيه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه هذه النقطه الاولى
النقطه الثانيه غمزه ان الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان يريد اقتتال في داخل التركي
على الاطلاق اليوم من بنى من اقام هذه
التنميه الحضاريه في الوحده الوطنيه من
المستحيل ان يتوجه الى اي اقتتال او يزرع
اي فتنه على الاطلاق وبالتالي هذا الكلام
ساقط بكل تاكيد لا مجال لتشبيه نظام بنى
تركيا بانظمه تقتل شعوب هذا والنظام
السوري يقتل الشعوب براميل متفجره
من الامور اما تركيا تبني هذه تركيا في
الشمال السوري تبني وبالتالي لا مجال
للتشبيه
ساجيبك بعد قليل وبالتالي اليوم نظام
تركيا بنى على عكس الانظمه العربيه الاخرى
لا تتسرعوا يقول للشعوب العربيه عشرين سنه
20 سنه يا سيدي اين لا تتسرعوا الشعوب
العربيه واعيه وانا لا اسبح من على هذا
العاطف لا اسمح ان يقول عن العرب انهم
عاطفيين عن كلمه عاطفي بهذا السياق اي
انهم لا يفهمون شيء هذا الامر غير صحيح
العرب بنوا عبر التاريخ حضارات وفتحوا مدن
وقادوا جيوش وانتصروا وبالتالي ليسوا
اغبياء وليسوا عاطفين خليك هون يعرفون هم
يعرفون ان اردوغان رجل دوله ناجح لذلك
يفرحون
بس نقطه مهمه وهذه النقطه دكتور محمد يعني
انت تصف هذه الفرحه او هذا الاهتمام
العربي والاسلامي والدوله او خلينا
بالعربي والاسلامي الان بانهم يعني لا
تستعجلوا لا تستعجلوا وان الذين فرحوا
وصفقوا وهنئوا والى ما هنالك كانوا
عاطفيين لماذا لا نقول ان الشارع العربي
على العكس تماما على العكس تماما يعرف
البير غطاء اذا صح التعبير وهو عندما يصفق
لفوز اردوغان او لهذه الديمقراطيه التركيه
العظيمه بصراحه قل لي بس دوله اوروبيه او
امريكيه شارك 89% من الشعب في الانتخابات
لم يحدث في تاريخ الديمقراطيات كلها بتعرف
احد المفكرين الامريكيين ماذا قال يوما
قال ان العدد الذي او النسبه التي تنتخب
الرئيس الامريكي 18% فقط 18% من
الامريكيين يصوتون لا احد في تركيا 89 مش
هيك اول مره
لماذا لا نقول لماذا لا نقول ان هذه
الفرحه او هذه يعني الفرحه العارمه اذا صح
التعبير او الضجه الكبيره في الشارع
العربي
مردها الى ان العرب باتوا يتوقون الى
الديمقراطيه باتوا يريدون زعيما وطنيا
كاردوغان وليس كالتراطير المبتلين بهم
والطغاه والولوه الى ما هنالك من هذا
الكلام اردوغان يمثل لشارع العربي
والاسلامي انا لا ادافع عنه يمثل بصيص امل
لماذا لا نكون مثل تركيا سوريا لماذا
سوريا وتركيا كلها ضربه مطيطه ضربه مطيطه
بتعرف المطيطه بسموها نقيفه ماشي طيب
لماذا لا يكون عنا مثله لماذا في تركيا
بفوز اردوغان بعد ان حقق لتركيا صنع
غواصات وصنع طائرات مسيره وصنع والعمل
معجزات وباخر النهار جاب 52 عنا ابو البيش
اه قتل مليون سوري عذب مئات الالاف شرد
نصف الشعب السوري دمرت ثلاثه ارباع سوريا
واخو شليتي باخر النهار بفوز ب 99% وحتى
بيروح بدور على الواحد اللي ما صوت مشان
يقتله شو رايك انت هذا الرجل الذي تتحدث
عنه ويهرول الان الى النظام السوري يا
سيدي يشكل اكبر طعنه وغدر بالثوره السوريه
هو الرئيس اردوغان اليوم التحول العربي في
حدث طرقت على الموضوع السوري التحول
العربي في عوده الاسد الى الجامعه العربيه
ويعني التخلي عن المعارضه اليوم الدور
الذي يلعبه اردوغان
المسيرات الى اذربيجان وارسل المسيرات الى
كل مكان سبحان الله هذه المسيرات ضلت
طريقها عن القدس يعني نفس نفس ايران تمام
هذا كلام عاطفي في كل مكان في القدس وفي
ذلك الرئيس التركي يعني ما هذا قائد الامه
الاسلاميه هل ارسل الجيوش ومن هنا من منبر
الجزيره وعلى سيره انه النظام السوري يعني
كان عنده مستشارين عسكريين ايرانيين
ونيابه عن الشعب الفلسطيني اقول من مبر
الجزيره نحن نطالب الرئيس اردوغان بارسال
مستشارين عسكريين ايرانيين الى القدس
وليعينوا المقاومه الفلسطينيين
ايرانيين لا يعرف ماذا يقول كما ارسل
الاسد
مستشاريات ولا نريد مقاتلين ولا نريد دعم
ارسل لنا مستشارين عسكريين اتراك الى
فلسطين يساند المقاومه الفلسطينيه هل هو
هل مسموح ذلك انت تتحدث على دور عظيم
لتركيا اي دور عظيم وتح اليد الاسرائيليه
وتضع له حدود ابدا على المحاك اردوغان على
المحاك لا يستطيع ان يخرج عن العباءه
الامريكيه وانت رايت في ذروه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا والتفاعل مع هذه
الحرب وكيف انيتوا وقف الى جانب اوكرانيا
بهذا الدعم الكبير ماذا كان موقف الرئيس
التركي وهو بالامس قبل الحرب الذي ذهب الى
اوكرانيا واطلق صيحته من هناك المشهوره
المجد لاوكرانيا
بمقدار ارسلها الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وانما هو بطل سياسه المتناقضات وبطل سياسه
الجري في ملاعب الخصوم تاره يجري في
الملعب الامريكي وتاره يجري في الملعب
الروسي
انت قد تضطر نعم ان تكون انت متناقضا في
سياستك ولكن الى حد معين وفي لحظه معينه
يجب ان يحكمك الثبات السياسي لان
الاستمرار في هذه التناقضات والاستمرار في
هذه الجري في ملاعب الكبار سوف يفقدك في
النهايه الهيبه وهو اسس بطبيعه الحال هذا
التدخل في ملفات عديده في جبهات المنطقه
اسس لهذا الانهيار الاقتصادي الذين نراه
ويعاني منه المواطن التركي ويقول لك دور
تركيا دوله مقبله على تقدم كبير لك اي
تقدم يا سيدي اليوم انا اتن من المانيا
والله يا دكتور نرى في اوروبا مئات
الاتراك يلجاون الى اوروبا لماذا يلجا
المواطن التركي الى اوروبا هذه الايام وهو
يرى هذا التدهور الاقتصادي الكبير اليوم
اديش سعر الصرف الليره التركيه امام
الدولار ساجيبك مفرد ان فتحت هذا الموضوع
انا اريدك ان تفتح موضوع الليره التركيه
هذا الذي اريده بدايه نقاط سجلتها في
المداخله الاولى لا اريد ان ارد عليها
قضيه ان يفتح جبهات كثيره وهذا يعني قوي
هذا يعني قوه هذا يشير اردوغان استاذ ضيفك
عن هذه الاخطاء لا ابدا مستمر
بس دقيقه بس جاوبني طيب اذا كان لماذا كان
كذلك طيب الا ترى ان هناك نوعا من تصحيح
كل الاخطاء يعني مثلا الان عندما يعود الى
مصر عندما يعود الى سوريا انت نعود الى
الخليج عندما عندما
بدايه واحده واحده يقول المثل
رحم الله امرئ عرف حده عرف قدره فوقف عند
هذا لا ينطبق على هذا لا ينطبق علينا في
تركيا الجديده نحن
وسنزيد هذا الحد ونعمل اقوى ليكون حدنا
اقوى اوسع واكثر والمستقبل لتركيا
وحلفاء تركيا وبالتالي اليوم هذه هي تركيا
القويه لن نلتزم بالحدود التي وضعت قبل
مئه عام سكس فيكو لن نلتزم بهذه الحدود
سنناصر كل مطلوب يطلب منا الاسره اما
سياسيا حيث نستطيع اما عسكريه اما انسانيه
يا حمزه انت تعلم ان هذه السياسات كان لها
نتائج خطيره على الاقتصاد التركي على
الوضع التركي هل تستطيعون ان تقفوا في وجه
امريكا واوروبا انت تعلم انت شاهدت بام
عينيك الحمله الاعلاميه الغربيه على
اردوغان وعلى حزب العداله والتنميه انتم
تواجهون ايضا تحديات كبرى غربيه
لقاء دكتور فيصل نحن واجه تحديات ونحن على
قدر هذه التحديات وسننتصر في نهايه المطاف
اردوغان لم يصل الى هذه المكانه يعني في
ليله وضحاها 45 سنه من التحديات سجن الرجل
وبالتالي نحن على قدر التحديات فيما يتعلق
بالقضيه الدينيه والانقسام الديني هل هذه
الدينيه متحجبه تحتفل بفوز اردوغان كلا
يعني ليست متحجبه هذه في طرابلس لبنان
الشعوب العربيه تحتفل في الكويت بعد فتره
واعون الجماعه في قطر هنا عاطفيين في
الجزائر في البانيا يا دكتور فيصل في
لبنان
غزه غزه التي يتحدث كلنا نعرف حجم الدعم
لفلسطين من تركيا كلنا نعلم
التركيه والمعنوي والسياسي
يقول لك وكلنا نعلم حجم الاستثمارات
الاسرائيليه في تركيا
الى هذه الانظمه هذا هذا التصور من يطرح
هذا الامر غير دقيق حلو تلك الانظمه فشلت
باسقاط اردوغان تامرت عليه اعلاميا وماليا
في الالفين 2018 وحاول اسقاط الليره
التركيه تامروا عليه عسكريا بالانقلاب
يدعمون تنظيم بيكاكا ارهابي تركيا تواجه
امريكا عندما نقتل هؤلاء نحن نواجه امريكا
ها هو الضابط الامريكي وهذا تم تصفيته
ببين اقدار التركيه اي نحن نواجه امريكا
نعم قادرون مواجهه امريكا من خلال
تحالفاتنا مع الاخرين ليست امريكا فقط في
العالم نحن لدينا العالم التركي العالم
التركي قادم يا دكتور فيصل حتى حدود الصين
انا بهذه الهويه التركيه بهذه الهويه
التركيه ساصل الى حدود الصين قريبا بدون
جواز سفر هذا ماذا يعني هذا يعني قوه
اقليميه لتركيا الانظمه التي ذكرتها قبل
قليل هذه الانظمه فشلت كما ذكرت وهي التي
عادت لتركيا ووجدت الباب مفتوح اللي
بالنسبه لتركيا اليوم مصر لم تستطع ان
تحرك بارجه واحده وقطعه واحده شرقي
المتوسط لسلب حقوق تركيا في ما يتعلق
بالغاز وفي نهايه المطاف وجدت انه الحل مع
تركيا وتركي قالت اهلا وسهلا اسرائيل
اليوم القضيه ليس ان استقبل الرئيس
الاسرائيلي او لا استقبل اليوم ضيفك في
احد احدى المقالات يقول النظام السوري قوه
موجوده ويجب التعامل معه اسرائيل هي دوله
احتلال وهي غاصمه وارهابيه ونحن كشعب
نستقبل
ولكن
على اساس ان الديه على اساس الفوقيه مع
اسرائيل نحن اعلى من اسرائيل قبل اردوغان
كانت اسرائيل متحكمه بالمنطقه كانت
اسرائيل متحكمه بتركيا اليوم لا اليوم
تركيا تمنع اسرائيل يا دكتور فيصل تمنعها
من مد خرطوم لتصدير الغاز الى اوروبا لا
تستطيع اسرائيل ان تصدر هذا الغاز الا
باذن من تركيا اليوم النظام السوري قضيه
سوريا وقضيه مهمه وغالبيه من يشاهدوننا
الان هم من الاخوه السوريين الذين احتفلوا
انظر للاحتفالات في الشمال السوري علم
الثوره السوريه
على الاطلاق اليوم نحن نحتضر الاخوه
السوريين احباب واخوه واليوم التركي عانق
السوري كما ارسل لاحد الاخوه السوريين على
الواتساب عانقوا بعضهم فرحا بفوز اردوغان
اليوم هذه الصوره الجميله للشعوب العربيه
والاسلاميه لا يريد امثال هؤلاء يريدون ان
تبقى الشعوب العربيه والاسلاميه متشتته
متفتته عندما شيء ولو معنى ويفرحهم نرى
هذه التصريحات ونرى هذا التدمير لكل هذه
الفرحه ولكن في نهايه المطاف كما فرحنا
وانتصرنا سابقا نحن سننتصر في المرحله
المقبله النظام السوري لن يستطيع ان ياخذ
من تركيا الا ما تريد تركيا النظام السوري
في لحظه ضعف النظام السوري نظام
سورية والحوار مع تركيا اليوم الجميع ادرك
انه لا يمكن حل القضيه السوريه الا برضا
تركي وتركيا لن تتخلى عن الثوره السوريه
وعن الشعب السوري على الاطلاق اليوم على
الاطلاق يا سلام العلاقات بين تركيا
والشعب السوري في الشمال السوري يا دكتور
فيصل هناك 6 مليون مواطن صح جمال السوري
ليس قليل هناك سته مليون مهجه خارج سوريا
وبالتالي بشار الاسد لا يمر على نصف سوريا
سمعناها من مسؤول تركي في الامم المتحده
قال تركيا اولى بالتفاوض عن عن القضيه
السوريه من النظام السوري عدد السوريين
تحت السيطره التركيه اكثر من عدد السوري
يكون في الشمال السوري للتنميه بالتعاون
بين تركيا وقطر هذا ماذا يعني هذه ما هي
الرساله اننا هنا وبالتالي الجيش التركي
في سوريا لن ينسحب ولن يتخلى عن الشمال
السوري الا ان يخضع النظام السوري لشروط
تركيا
هلا
تحدثت عن انه الغرب ضد تركيا وامريكا ضد
تركيا
تواجه الكثير والكثير طب لماذا لا نقول
لماذا لا نقول ان ثبات الموقف التركي
وصلابه الموقف التركي الاردني تحديدا هو
الذي جعل الاخرين
يعيدون النظر في مواقفهم وتصرفاتهم انت
لاحظت نرجع بنكررها المجلات الفرنسيه
البريطانيه الامريكيه لم يبقى مجله الا
حرضت ضد اردوغان حرض ضد اردوغان ماذا حدث
حدث العكس الان ماذا تفعل الدول الاوروبيه
التي حرضت او الدول العالميه التي حرضت ضد
اردوغان واعلامها بعض المجلات الاوروبيه
سحبت المقالات القديمه التي حرضت فيها ضد
الرئيس التركي سحبت دقيقه
والاخرون الذي مثلا الرئيس الامريكي كم
مره كم مره سمعناه يقول يجب على اردوغان
ان يذهب الامريكي البريطاني الفرنسي كلهم
كانوا يريدون لاردوغان ان يذهب ثبات
اردوغان كان كالشوكه في عيونهم والان ماذا
يقولون الرئيس الامريكي نحن مستعدون
للتعامل مع السلطه المنتخبه
الفرنسي يقول نفس الكلام السويدي يقول نفس
الكلام الالماني يقول نفس الكلام اذا من
الذي انتصر
من الذي يعيد اوراقه الان ووجهات نظره
الغرب واعداء تركيا كيف ترد هذا الكلام
غير صحيح على الاطلاق اليوم يعني ينتقد
الغرب ويقول ان الغرب وقف ضد اردوغان
السؤال الكبير من الذي يلهث لي الانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي اليس الرئيس التركي
يفاوضون منذ العام 2005 على الانضمام الى
اوروبا تقول انهم لماذا يعني يباركون فوز
الرئيس التركي يا سيدي اردوغان يملك ورقه
كبيره هي ورقه اللاجئين انت تتحدث عن اكثر
من ثلاثه ملايين لاجئ موجودون الان في
تركيا لا اعرف بالضبط الرقم ولكن هذا
الاستثمار في ورقه اللاجئين وهدد اردوغان
كان يهدد دائما اذا لم تعطوني اموال هذه
السياسي هذه
فتح الموضوع السوري
يستوجب الرد
الحاكم
اكثر متامرين على القضيه السوريه هم
الاتراك هم الاتراك حزب العداله والتنميه
تتحدث عن الشعب السوري شعبكم دماء الذين
عذبوا وقتلوا على الحدود لم تجف الذين
قتلوا من الذي حاسبه
واليوم يتحدثون عن يعني انا اريد ان
اطرحها يعني اليوم يتحدثون عن البدء
بتسليم بعض المعارضين السوريين للنظام
اردوغان سوف يجهز على ما تبقى من المعارضه
السوريه يقول لك على المستوى الشعبي من
الذي صدع رؤوسنا عبر السنوات الماضيه
بنظريه المهاجرين والانصار اليس الرئيس
التركي اين اصبحت هذه النظريه في سله
المهملات المعارضه السوريه المسلحه التي
دعمها اردوغان وسلحها وسهل لها كل الامور
في لحظه بعينها ماذا فعل استثمر في هذه في
هذه المعارضه استثمر في دماء السوريين
وكلنا يعرف كيف بعث هذه الفصائل لتقاتل في
ليبيا اليوم يقول لك يتهمونك للجدار بدعم
بقي ومن دعمتم انتم في لحظه معينه وفي
فتره معينه الم تدعمو داعش الم تدعموا
جبهه النصره اسال الذين لجاوا الى اوروبا
عبر المعبر البري كيف مروا من تركيا الى
اوروبا على العين الجبهه النصره وعين
الجندرمه التركيه يقول لك لا ندعم تنظيم
ارهابي الموضوع ذكرت نقطه كثير مهمه انه
اليس الاراده الامريكيه تشكل عائق امام
تركيا لكي يعني تغير خياراتها هذا جدا
صحيح تركيا اليوم لا تستطيع ان تخرج من
العباءه الامريكيه ومن القرار الامريكي
السياسي ومن قرار منظمه النيتو تحديدا
بقاء التركي في منظمه
الا تعتقد ان الموقف التركي حيال الحرب
الاوكرانيه من تدعم مع من تتعامل تركيا في
تتعامل مع روسيا تتعامل مع روسيا في في
بشان الاوكراني بالشان السوري تتعامل مع
ايران اذا تركيا لديها استقلاليه كبيره في
هذا الامر لديها استقلاليه على عكس
المطلوب منها اوروبيا
واطلسيا وامريكيا والى ما هنالك من هذا
الكلام تركيا تدفع ثمن مواقفها
المستقله او ولا لا لا بالتاكيد لا تركيا
تتعامل مع روسيا راينا الموقف التركي
الصارخ المنحاز لاوكرانيا وقلت لك مسيرات
بمقدار يعني سلمها ليقصف بها الجيش الروسي
هو مضطر للتعامل وترى في هذا الاعلام
العوده الروسيه التركيه الى روسيا يعني
لان تركيا بحاجه الى روسيا تركيا غير
منتجه للغاز والغاز الروسي هو مهم ايران
كذلك يعني في قمه ايران الاخيره وقعوا
اتفاقات اق طويله الامد وبالتالي العوده
التركيه لهذه الدول ليس من باب العود
الاحمد هو يقيم مرحله بعينها يريد من هذه
الدول ان تمده بالطاقه وبالتالي نفسر هذه
العوده الرئيس التركي طالما بقي في منظومه
الناتو لن يستطيع ان يخرج من دونها لان
هذه العباءه بالتاكيد لانه يدرك ان اليوم
هذا التحالف الغربي بقياده النيتو له ثقل
وازن في المنظومه الدوليه وبالتالي الخروج
منه يشكل عبء على تركيا وبالتالي سوف يبقى
مضطرا لان يساير هذا ويساير ذاك وان يبقى
ضمن القرار الامريكي النيتوي جميل حمزه
تكن هذا الكلام يقودنا الى يعني التاثيرات
الغربيه على الواقع التركي الان طيب انا
بدي اسالك سؤال ماذا حصل لليره التركيه
بعد فوز اردوغان
هبطت هبطت الليره التركيه مقابل الدولار
ومقابل اليورو مقابل كذا طيب يعني
اليس في ذلك مؤشر على اين تتجه الامور
الان بعد فوز اردوغان بعدين انا اللي
بتسالك اياه ماذا يمكن لاردوغان والنظام
التركي بشكل عام ان يفعل اكثر مما فعله
ماذا لديكم ماذا لديكم
قضيه الليره قضيه مهمه عاده يا دكتور فيصل
النجاح واستقرار سياسي في تركيا الان
استقرار سياسي الرئيس والبرلمان من نفس
التوجه السياسي استقرار عاده عندما يحصل
استقرار يتحسن الاقتصاد والعمره العمله
يعني في اي بلد لماذا تراجعت العمله احدث
حدث العكس لماذا يشير الى هناك حرب على
الليره التركيه طيب هذا اللي عم اقول لك
اياه نعم هناك حرب بين وجه هذه الحرب
نواجه الحرب
يا حمزه انت تعلم ان الامريكيين عندما كان
الرئيس الامريكي يكتب تغريده في تويتر
كانت يعني الليره تهبل
على العمله التركيه هناك حرب بسبب
الاستقلال السياسي التركي الذي تسعى الى
نقطه النقطه الثانيه يا سيدي الكريم
وللمشاهدين الكرام تصريف العمله ليس هو
معيار للاقتصاد اليوم نحن نعرف العمله
اليابانيه في الحضيض العمله الصينيه
امريكا تضغط لتخفيف
والعمله الاردنيه تتصور مثلا ثابته
وبالتالي اين الاقتصاد الياباني في القمه
الصيني في القمه وبالتالي ليست العمله هي
معيار تراجع الليره التركيه ليس معيارا
للاقتصاد التركي انه يتراجع لان الاقتصاد
التركي ينمو ينمو وبالتالي الاقتصاد
التركي سي ينمو هذه السنه اكثر من السنه
على الاطلاق الاقتصاد التركي ينمو هيئه
الاقتصاد التركيه
الاقتصاديات رسميه لكن اخذ البيانات من
الشاميه انت دكتور من المفترض ان تعرف
دكتور حضرتك تاخذ
الرسميه
وبالتالي هذه الليره التركيه هذا وضع
الليره اريد ان ارد على نقاط كثيره قضيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ربما ضيفك غريب يعني ما
زال في عشرينيات او في قبل عشرين سنه هذه
الجمله مقبوله اما الان يا سيدي يا حبيبي
نحن نمنع السويد من الدخول للنيتو نحن
نمنع السويد السويد يعني تقبل تركيا قدم
اردوغان لتدخل الى الناتو اي عباءه نحن
لسنا
نحن عضو ولكن لسنا تحت عباءه
في الناتو
وانتم
تمنعون نحن اردوغان شخصيا اردوغان القوي
المنتصر المعتز بدينه يمنع السويد من
الدخول الى
السبب الاول دعم السويد للتنظيم الارهابي
والسبب الثاني تطاول السنيد على القران
الكريم وعلى الشعائر الاسلاميه هذه النقطه
الاولى تسليم المعارضين يا دكتور فيصل
اليوم من يحمل الجنسيه التركيه لا يعني
انه خارج القانون لا يعني انه يلعب ويسعد
عليها يلتزم حلو وبالتالي من يخالف
القوانين
هذه نقطه اساسيه حلو فيما يتعلق
بالمهاجرين رؤسار ما زالت قائمه واردوغان
دفع ثمن هذه القضيه بالانتخابات تراجع
التصويت له بانه يدافع عن المهاجرين لان
هناك جزء من العنصريين في تركيا
يدفع ثمن سياسي بهذه القضيه وبالتالي نحن
ما زلنا محافظين على هذه القضيه اليوم
السوريون في تركيا يعيشون بامن وسلام عدم
مخالفه القانون هذا طبيعي يعني داعش تركيا
من اكبر المحاربين لتنظيم داعش اكثر
المتضررين الف اكثر من 70 الف من اعضاء
داعش الاوروبيين وخاصه من المانيا التي
يسكن فيها ضيفك هم على لوائح المنع
موجودين في ممنوعين من دخول تركيا تركيا
شهدت تفجيرات ارهابيه قامت بها داعش تركيا
الجيش الوحيد الذي حارب داعش هو الجيش
وبالتالي نحن اقوياء نحن لسنا ضعفاء اليوم
يا سيدي الكريم قضيه الغاز يقول تركيا
ليست عندها غاز اين يعيش البحر الاسود
اين تعيش فاتوره الغاز اعطيني عمر اعطني
دوله
الغاز صفر نحن لمده سنه
هل دوله بالعالم
بالمجان للمواطنين هذه الفاتوره اكبر دليل
انه لا يوجد ازمه اقتصاديه في تركيا اليوم
لماذا لا نقول هذه هديه انتخابيه على
الاطلاق هذه لم
وبالتالي اليوم قضيه الغاز تركيا ستكون
محور الغاز في العالم هذه قوه الغاز
الايراني سيمر الى اوروبا عن طريق تركيا
والغاز العراقي والغاز الاثري وبالتالي
هذا مركز قوه لتركيا هذه نقطه
كيف ترد على هذه النقطه هل تستطيع ان تنكر
بان تركيا اصبحت بيضه القبان في المنطقه
في المنطقه والعالم الروسي
يخطب والتركيه الاوكراني يخطب والتركيه
الامريكي يخطب التركيه السويدي يخطب تركيا
الان اصبحت فعلا بيضه القبان هي التي تحدث
التوازنات
اتفاقيات الحبوب التي تطعم العالم اجمع من
راها راحتها الدبلوماسيه التركيه تستطيع
ان تنكر ذلك لا احد يستطيع ان ينكر ذلك
فما نهتم بانه معارض هون ومعارض هون
لنتحدث عن قضايا استراتيجيه كبرى يعني
تقوم بها بها تركيا هل تستطيع ان تنكر ذلك
هل تستطيع ان تنكر ان الشرق والغرب الان
ياتي الى تركيا
لحل قضايا ثم النقطه الاخيره بدي ترد لي
عليها انت قلت انه تركيا لا تستطيع ان
تخرج من عباءه الناتو ولا تستطيع ان تخرج
من العذاب من الذي اوقف انضمام السويد الى
حلف الناتو رغما عن انف امريكا واوروبا
والجميع من اردوغان ولا لا صحيح لا احد
ينكر ان تركيا هي دوله محوريه على مستوى
الاقليم هذا كله نسلم به لكن موضوع السويد
يعني يعني نكبر دور تركيا السويد استطاع
الرئيس التركي ان يلعب بهذا الموضوع دورا
محوريا لانه كما قلت لك يملك ورقه
اللاجئين اليوم اذا التركي
حلال على الشاطر يا دكتور يا دكتور هلا
انت حدث تحدث عن موضوع الغاز والموضوع انه
تركيا بيضه القبان طيب كيف تركيا بيضه
القبان وتذهب الى ايران وروسيا وتوقع
اتفاقيات كبيره
لاستيراد الغاز هذا او النقطه الاولى
النقطه الثانيه يتحدث عن انه الاقتصاد
التركي بخير طيب اقول لك هنا بيانات رسميه
رسميه البنك الاساس لا تعترف بالبيانات
الرسميه قبل قليل اتيت لك ببيان رسمي لا
اعتقد
يعني
الرسميه مجله الرسمي مجله
البنك المركزي التركي في الشهر مايو هذا
الحالي في العاشر في عشره خمسه تحديدا
يقول ولكل من يروج لي ان المناخ
الاستثماري في تركيا بخير يقول انخفض
انخفضت الوضاء الودائع بالعملات الاجنبيه
لغير المقيمين وللبنوك غير المقيمه
انخفاضا قدره 16.4 مليار دولار وارتفع
الدين قصير الاجل للقطاع العام بنسبه تسعه
ونص بالميه المؤسسات غير الرسم
لدى تركيا احتياجات تمويليه خارجيه كبيره
كذلك فان قطاعها الخاص والعام مثقل
بالديون المترتبه عليه بالعملات الاجنبيه
باختصار تركيا مقبله على تحديات كبيره لن
تستطيع تواجدها الجزائر
بدي منك جمله واحده ماذا يستطيع الرئيس
اردوغان بعد فوزه بولايه جديده ان يفعل
اكثر مما فعله انتهى كما فعل محمد الفاتح
نحن بذكرى فتح القسطنطينيه تمام محمد
الفاتح وحامله الطائرات التركيه من
التاريخ الى الحاضر اقرا التاريخ ماذا فعل
محمد الفاتح نحن سنقول اقوى من الدوله
العثمانيه سياسيا كيف ترد بجمله واحده لن
تكون تركيا قادره على مواجهه التحديات
الكبيره لان هذه التح
دي
سوف تبقى في الدور الاقليمي والسقفها هي
الاقليم
مع الكبار مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومع روسيا اشكرك جزيل الشكر مشاهدينا
الكرام لم يبقى لنا نشكر ضيفينا
حمزه تكن ومحمد بكر
نلتقي مساء ثلاثاء المقبل وحتى ذلك الحين
هو فيصل القاسم احييكم من الدوحه الى
اللقاء يعطيكم العافيه
[موسيقى]